[Music]
one way or another the path were on
leads to tennis together
we can stop him let's go
fairness is coming this might be
dangerous so let's put on our mean faces
[Music]
we're gonna need some help
my kid in the venture him
[Music]
everybody it's Charlie we got a whole
bunch of New Avengers to break down and
Avengers for can you tell us if you
anything as he walked the middle of it I
think that the Guardians just shocked
their part when it comes to infinity
Wars like the first part and we all have
to go back for gauntlets later this year
people have been speculating is the
reason why they haven't told us what the
title is is because it's gonna be a
spoiler and scare the [ __ ] out of people
in the russo say it should so I don't
know if it's spawned out of an old rumor
or if it's spawned out of some new April
Fool's joke because we just had April
Fool's and there was a lot of fake news
that went out just in the name of comedy
but there's a new potential Avengers for
title based on a classic Bendis story
that I'll try to explain and why I think
that it might actually be legit even
though there's still a number of options
but if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's also a new round
of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway too
unless a new winner at the end of this
obviously it's the national championship
so they're dropping new footage that I
attached at the beginning of this we got
some new crew to ative shots of Iron Man
we even got a better look at Spider
Man's iron spider armor you can actually
see like the nodules in the back here
that it looks like the iron spider legs
come out of before they actually started
dropping all the Infinity war promos
early speculation was is that it would
be like comic book iron spider in
everything that the suit did would be
contained within this suit but now that
we've got an actual look at it and we
know about Iron Man's bleeding-edge
armor and sort of the left turns they're
taking with a couple of the comic book
ideas it seems like they're gonna be
separate attachments or they're attached
to a separate part like it'll be more
practical than Iron Man's bleeding-edge
armor but because Sheree is so big in
the next two films and she teased that
she and tom hollander friends and on the
set they were talking a lot about her
helping him out with his suit we might
see them integrate some of those
functions into future versions of the
costume Tom's my friend and I was I was
contemplating helping him in the future
with his suit and stuff and just we were
just going back and forth but I think
the idea is they want to give Iron Man
all the super cool stuff first and then
it sort of trickles down to war machines
Spider Man anybody else that benefits
from his technology
you know Sheree and Black Panther -
because they're a big part of the
universe so anytime there's like a brand
new super cool thing it's usually black
or Ironman you should expect to show
that off first but the big Avengers for
title rumor is Avengers disassembled so
I'll remind everyone that that's still
in the rumor stage I don't know where
this picture came from
it's surfaced somewhere it could be part
of a rumor it could be part of an April
Fool's joke but based on the trolling
that the Russo brothers did it actually
does sound legit although I would think
that in the name of making billions and
billions of dollars on merchandising and
getting people to go see this do they
want to pick a more hopeful sounding
title but if you don't consider yourself
a big movie geek there's a lot of
marketing and research that goes in to
the titling and a lot of the branding of
these big billion-dollar movies like if
they're spending this much money on it
they want it to appeal to the broadest
possible audience so when they're
picking titles they want to pick
something that immediately tells a non
comic book reader just your average
person on the street what the movies
about and it sounds exciting enough for
them to want to go see like oh my god
this sounds crazy I have to go see it
even if they've never heard of any of
the comic book characters so given what
we know about infinity war about how the
Avengers are gonna get their asses
handed to them fantasy is gonna form the
gauntlet Avengers 4 will be the story of
them fixing the universe getting the
gauntlet off of his hand the avengers
sound like they're gonna be relatively
disassembled heading into that so it
sounds plausible just add it near to the
top of the list but there are things
like New Avengers
anything with Avengers in the title that
sounds really big splashy and kind of
hopeful but because they're burning the
title infinity war I don't think they
want to be super redundant so I wouldn't
be surprised if for Avengers 4 they
dropped the Infinity moniker and it just
became Avengers something or Avengers
something something that's also why
after that Zoe Saldana clip where she's
like we're going back for gauntlet
implying that at least internally they
were referring to Avengers 4 as Avengers
the Infinity Gauntlet because Thanos had
assembled it James Gunn came out because
this was all back during guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 stuff and he was like
you know what I'm gonna have a
talking-to with her because that's not
actually what it's called and he is like
executive producer on these next two
Avengers films so if anybody knows what
the title is it's him it him saying that
gauntlet is nowhere in the title just
lends more credence to the idea that
they're picking something that's a
little more WTF and completely
unexpected
just remember when your theory
lefting shorter titles generally tend to
be better if he can accomplish all of
its goals getting people really excited
to go see the movie in a shorter amount
of characters then that's usually what
they go with simpler is always better
but if you did not read that Avengers
disassembled storyline is actually from
way way back more than 10 years ago
almost 15 years ago it was the very
beginning of Bendis as run on the
avengers and remember he's the person
that's most known for new Avengers
disassembled was the story he used to
cycle the roster in r.i.p hawkeye he
wound up killing Hawkeye during that
story but that's also the story where
like she Hulk gets mind-controlled and
rips vision apart so there's a lot of
big WTF moments that people might
remember but it was all Bendis just
saying okay we're gonna destroy the old
team and out of the ashes the New
Avengers will rise so I am waiting for
them to title one of these future
Avengers films the new avengers because
it's a really simple title and it's
literally what it will be it'll be the
new roster after these two big Avengers
films but I don't know that they would
burn that this soon the only thing that
I've taken off the table that is like
super clickable and really exciting
sounding is Avengers secret wars we can
revisit that when they have a better
chance for integrating Fox characters
which is probably still a couple years
off because remember they delayed Dark
Phoenix to next year meaning that
there's probably not gonna be any kind
of Fox Marvel crossover for at least a
couple more years I'm guessing about
three years but anything is possible
that you can see that Marvel logo on any
of the Fox movies recently I happen to
be sitting next to Hugh Jackman at this
Wow all right here we go what other
awkward thing I could talk about but to
be like am I gonna see soon
and but he said a couple of things to me
and I'll just I'll just leave it at that
because I feel like otherwise I'm gonna
get into trouble with somebody for the
most part it's gonna be business as
usual with all the Fox stuff for the
next couple of years so that means dark
Phoenix New Mutants Deadpool x-force any
future Deadpool movies for that matter
as long as it's one of their big
franchises but if you're not a big comic
book reader just a reminder that that
Avengers disassembled storyline was not
a Thanos infinity war storyline it I had
nothing to do with the infinity saga it
was all dr. doom trying to dismantle the
Avengers so that would be a big Fox
crossover they can still do that at a
future point but they're kind of being
disassembled in infinity war so feel
kind of redundant so post all your
theories in the comments below and what
will happen is because it's the national
championships is it there is new footage
I'll do a video for it tomorrow no
worries there's a bunch of stuff
happening so just check that top pink
comment for what my next couple of
videos are going to be congratulations
to the giveaway winner from my last big
video pine please private message me so
I can get your contact details click
here for that teen Thor trailer and
click here to learn all about the flash
season 5 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]